(upbeat music)
(wine pouring)
- Hello everybody and
welcome to wine library T...
Hello everybody, and welcome to the...
I don't even remember.
Hello everybody.
And welcome to Wine Library TV.
Yep. Ready?
- (DRock) Yep.
- Hello everybody and
welcome to Wine Library TV.
I am your host, Gary Vaynerchuk.
And this is episode 1003, DRock?
- (DRock) Three.
- Three of the thunder show,
AKA the Internet's most passionate
wine program.
And isn't this (bleep) fantastic.
And you gotta beep that DRock,
'cause I don't curse on the thunder show.
A lot of things have changed,
through that half decade
of doing this show
every day, five days a week.
I mean at five years and
we got a thousand shows in
and I only did it Monday through Friday.
So I was consistent.
I miss so many of you,
all the Vayniacs out there
and welcome to all the new people.
I'm sure the team, it is not Eric Kastner.
It is not Chris Mott to clear that up.
That was not my mother
ma I was saying Mott.
It is DRock in the building who,
if you watch my transition
after Wine Library TV
in business and entrepreneurial and
has been by my side for a long time,
and we are excited to do episode 1003.
If you look back at episode 1001 or 1002,
I ended at episode 1000.
I talk about doing these occasionally,
like Barbara Walters specials
and I'll do them four times a year.
Well, I think it's the
first episode I'm doing
in four years.
So a lot's been going on.
The Jets continue to struggle.
We are 0 in 10 in this season.
So I know that...
You know what's really funny,
the episodes of Wine Library TV,
we were during some good
years of Jets football.
It's been rough.
We have not made the playoffs
now for 10 straight years.
So maybe I should start
doing Wine Library TV again,
because 06 to 11 was like a
great run of Jets football.
Maybe that's actually the missing part.
Maybe Wine Library TV is the key
to Jets good football.
Anyway, everyone's good.
Thank you so much to all of you
that have signed up for Wine Text.
That's the big innovation
back at the shop.
VaynerMedia and all this
other stuff has happened.
There's plenty to catch up on,
but I don't want take up this time.
What I want do, is do
this holiday episode.
If nothing else, I can do this once a year
to talk about holiday wine,
what's going on in the wine world.
So many of you know, I started
a brand called Empathy Wines.
We sold at a consolation.
That's been exciting.
And since I've last left you,
I've been more and more into wine.
I drink more wine...
When I was doing Wine Library TV,
I never had wine at dinner.
It was so much of my profession.
I never drank wine at dinner.
I now drink wine all the time at dinner
and I've been more into the
wine world as a consumer.
And a lot of things have changed.
For example, why we chose wine number one
and I'm excited to taste it.
Is, as many of you may remember,
and this is the Phifer Pavit
Date Nights Sauvignon Blanc,
2018, Napa Valley.
20, $30, depending on
where you buy it from,
91 points, wine spectator.
Talk about a fun wine to start with,
during my great and fun,
and amazing five-year run
on Wine Library TV...
I'm sorry, the Jets bucket is around.
Today, we have a, like a
coffee grinder spittoon,
but we will find the Jet's
bucket if we get this going.
Talk about something that has changed,
in my opinion, and the markets.
I, along with the American
consumer during 2006 to 2011,
my golden year of Wine Library TV,
were not about that Napa Valley
or California Sauvignon Blanc.
As a matter of fact, I think I famously,
at least to myself, said that it was...
that all the Sauvignon Blanc,
all the Sauvignon Blanc in California,
should be ripped up and
replanted a different grape.
That's how down I was.
That's how high I was
on San Sierra and New
Zealand Sauvignon Blanc.
And that's just how I felt.
Over the last 18 months, I've been stunned
by my overall appreciation for
California Sauvignon Blanc.
I think the style has
evolved, more balanced,
less sugary, less goopy.
The wine world itself has gone
and followed a lot of
food and health trends.
If you look at, kind of, clean eating,
kind of vegan life, just really not...
Just, actually being thoughtful
about what you're putting in your body.
You look at the natural wine craze.
You look at the alcohol levels
and wine coming down in
California, more balanced.
And it's been really
interesting and fun to watch.
And, it's funny, I'm curious
how I'm gonna review this wine.
I hope I don't pan it.
And I'm happy to, as you know
for everybody's watching,
I'm excited for one of
these wines to get some heat
or we can go four for four.
We can go for four.
You never really know.
But I want to say before
I get into the wine
in case I don't like
this one New Zealand...
Excuse me, California Sauvignon Blanc
has made a tremendous comeback
in overall consumption.
And has been something
I've been lately fond of
and it's a tremendous consistent producer.
So let's give it a sniffy sniff.
On the nose I get a little bit
of oyster shell, very fresh
very sea ocean life.
I get a hint of a melon, call
it cantaloupe on the nose.
Little hint of lemon
and lime coming through.
So, the classic oysters and cantaloupe
with little Sprite poured on top of it.
Nice nose.
Let's give it a whirl.
Gorgeous acidity throughout this wine,
a banana peel
meets granny Smith Apple,
mid palette.
Huge acid on the finish.
I still am tasting it.
Gorgeous acidity.
Now, why is acidity important?
When I taste this wine,
I know I can use it to cut
through a lot of sea foods;
scallops, oysters, clams.
You get into that seafood life.
Even I'm thinking lobster tail in butter,
but this wine has the acidity cut-through
and match that wine.
Not be overpowered by the food,
but the wine itself is balanced
and will overpower the wine.
No alcohol in the flavor, beautiful apple.
I really get the granny Apple Smith,
apple on this beautiful finish.
If you just like a nice fresh salad,
I think this wine would
pair extremely well,
at 20 to 30 bucks, a really strong value.
Doesn't have the minerality
of a great Sancerre
that I'm a fan of in that 30, $40 range
but this stands up and this continues
the momentum that I told you.
Spectator gave a 91 points to me.
This is a 90 pointer as well.
I'll give it 90+
being a little tough against
the spectator right now
but this is a beautiful Sauvignon Blanc.
And if you can find it under 20
this can get into case wine
life during the summer.
This is really nice.
If you're watching me, I don't know
if we're putting this
out or what are we doing?
When are we putting it out?
- (DRock)Should be out before Thursday.
- Yeah. I mean, if you can
if we put this out on Monday
or Tuesday of next week
and you can pick up this wine
for Thanksgiving, if they have
in your local store, this
is a perfect stuffing.
This is a perfect aperitif
when you have people over
and not a whole lot of
people over during COVID
but this is a tremendous
pool time wine.
Like this is summer in a bottle.
Beautiful wine.
Nice complexity.
Great start.
Glad. I feel like one
of those episodes DRock
on one of my comeback episodes, 101 or 102
all the wines didn't do well or something.
I felt like a real
Debbie downer look back.
You don't remember her face, but you know
like real Debbie downer,
let's get into this one.
I've been hearing huge
hype about this Marnet
Marnet Cambell ranch, Pinot Noir
92 points wine spectator,
50 bucks, Sonoma Coast Pinot.
I think...
You know, it's funny that
they put this in the box.
I thought I'd do this
for a monthly wine club.
If you haven't signed up for
my wine of the month club,
go to winelibrary.com.
I thought, I'd be hearing
so much about Marnet
in general.
I there's a dark horse chance
I've had this wine already.
Let's see if I'm consistent
for, so everybody's part
of the wine club.
Dig up the videos.
I don't recall
This just...
Pinot Noir if you remember,
this is why I have the Pinot
and the Barolo in the
heyday of my 2006, 2011
Wine Library TV, pinot was exploding.
Burgundy was exploding.
And I was talking about
Barolo being the next thing to
explode. Well, sure enough.
You know, I like a good
Monday morning quarterback.
Here we are nine, 10 years
later and we nailed that.
Barolo exploded in value.
We were so honored.
I hope a lot of you followed
me back then and loaded up
on Barolo pros.
You can buy for 40, 60 bucks
back then, or now three
400 a bottle.
It changed.
And so I thought it'd
be fun to have here and
in some super culty,
California wine that I know
for the holidays buy for
your boss, buy for yourself
kind of buy for Christmas and
all the other holiday dinners.
So we have a big Insignia to
wrap us up, but the Barolo is
here for that reason.
And we have a Pinot for that reason.
These are two bookend wines.
Since I've been missing you.
This was the exploding wine
that emerged Pinot sideways.
I don't drink Merlot, all that.
And Barolo has become the
fancy of the wine world last
five to 10 years.
So excited about this
Marnet, single vineyard
Campbell ranch, beautiful
nose, little bacon, fat
huge strawberries
just gorgeous fields,
strawberry fields forever.
Wow!
Since I've last left
you, I've had the luxury
of traveling the world
quite a bit and staying
in some really, really,
really, really fancy hotels.
This wine's silkiness is like
the nicest silkiest sheets
from the most expensive Ritz
Carlton or Four Seasons.
You can imagine just
silk all the way through
beautiful red fruit, raspberries
strawberries throughout.
I get a little rose
petal on the mid palate
and a wonderful beef jerky
like premium beef jerky.
This is not Machoman.
Randy Savage Slim Jim ooh yeah beef jerky.
This is the really expensive
$38 at the Fancy Food Show
beef jerky on the mid
palette comes together
in this incredible $50 Pinot
Noir that in my opinion
rivals $100 red burgundies
that I have every day
of the week, AKA 15 times a year.
This is extraordinary.
92 points, wine spectator.
Whereas I thought the
spectator was a half a
point high here.
I think there are two
full points low here.
To me, this is a 94 point
Pinot Noir and anything
and anywhere you can get it
under 50 is a humongous buy.
You're probably going to see this wine.
If you write it down
on a restaurant list
at a good wine program
more than you're going to find it online
or at a retailer.
I mean, if you can get
this for less than a buck
50 a bottle on a wine list,
it is your wine of the night.
This is drinking great now.
But if you go out and find
this 18, 2018 vintage wine
and you're really into Pinot
and there it is 13 eight
and this is the beauty I'm telling you
the wines have come back to balance.
Since I left, have, you know
some of these were 15 fives, Pinot
too much alcohol, too much
makeup, too much extra.
You know, the world's gone extravagant.
You know, you go on Instagram.
It's a little bit glammed up.
It's a little bit fake
life, but the wines have
come back to match our food
like cleaner, simpler realer.
And I like that 94 points on this wine.
This is a steal to me.
Pick it, pick it up.
If you can find it.
If you drink, Sea Smoke
Kosta Browne, Rochioli like
this is, this is a real,
that's a beast of a wine.
Really good.
All right.
I'm super excited about this.
COPPO 2015, Barolo really fun.
Vintage 30 to $40, 90
points wine enthusiast
13 five alcohol big fan
of this producer have always
been loved the late 90 versions
or 2001 of this wine.
Really excited about this 15.
I've always liked this winery a lot now
because you can see
colors a little different
not as pitch-black as some
wines, you're going to
see this color that you're
going to see just black.
This is more brownish and, and red.
I love that.
I love that COPPO love
Barolo Nebbiolo based.
Which is the great
not the kind of nose I would
have expected from this wine.
To be honest, a little tight.
I've had some 15 Barolos
that have been more exciting
on the nose.
Yeah a little disappointing.
Let me warm it up a
little, but tight, tight.
Like I used oysters earlier,
you know that oyster
that's not fully open and
you're always wondering
with your friends, like,
but it's kind of open, like
should we eat it?
And you kind of like you
kind of a little scared.
You're like it didn't open.
So maybe that's a proud,
you know, you know that
you know what I'm talking
about with breaking rock
with the clay, you know, I'm
always the one that's like
I'll go there.
And it's probably why I throw
up sometimes at three o'clock
in the morning from food
poisoning, but like, you know
most people pass that's
what's going on here.
This is like a tight little clam
and it may not be worth entering.
Disappointment alert.
Disappointment alert,
a winery that I've loved for years.
A vintage I love,
a wine I just hyped up for a minute.
Before we got here, this
wine is wildly underwhelming
has completely missed my expectations.
This is like somebody you
hired for your business
that you think is going to come in
and change the course of your company.
And you realize by week two
you need to fire their sorry ass.
This is a sorry ass wine.
90 points wine enthusiast
is completely overrated.
Even at the inexpensive 30 to $35
at this Barolo can be, this
is not, this is not exciting.
Shockingly thin like kind of like when
you see your friend post COVID
and they were working out and
eating well the whole year
shockingly thin is why
needs a lot more complexity.
Wow, this is, this is really not good.
You know, I'm a little rusty,
but this to me is an 84 point wine.
It's a major pass with seven Zs, PA zzz.
This is...
I've had a shocking amount
of wine under $15 a bottle
in the last two years
that blows this wine away.
Do not pick this up, do not
buy this alert your friends
take a screenshot, text them.
This is a bad wine.
Things can change quick
here DRock. That was-
- (DRock) Pretty tough.
- Yeah, it was rough, man.
It was not.
This is not a good wine.
One man's point of view.
Trust your own palate.
Don't listen to me.
Don't listen to the wine spectator
Robert Parker or your favorite someone.
Listened to yourself.
That being said,
I've tasted a lot of wine in my life
and that's some (murmurs)
All right.
The big dog, Joseph Phelps Insignia 2014
an iconic wine 97 points, James Suckling
97 points, Wine Advocate,
87% Cabernet
9% Petit Verdot, 2% Cabernet Franc
2% Malbeck $200 a bottle.
If you can even find one
really excited about this 1994
Joseph Phelps Insignia.
This wine put me on the map.
The 1994 of this wine,
was a wine that I bought
an enormous amount of
everybody in the country
was selling it for 60 bucks.
I paid $ 39.99 a bottle
and I bought a $30,000 full-page
ad in the New York times,
and in that ad, 80% of the
real estate was a picture
of this wine and it said $39.99 on sale.
And it was a catapult moment
in winelibrary.com's history.
So I will forever have enormous love
for Joseph Phelps Insignia
from that moment and went on
to become one of the most iconic.
At that point it wasn't what it is today.
It was not on the Opus One,
on the Caymus Special site.
It was not in that league,
but over the last 25 years
that has built itself up
to being one of the most
significant wines in California.
And I'm always so honored
and excited to taste it.
Great color and remember I
made that reference earlier.
You can see the difference
that you know, light
which is not bad.
Light is great.
Just cause the COPPO wasn't a good wine.
In my opinion, I like light
Beaujolais Pinot Noir.
Barolo I love light, but
this is dark powerhouse wine.
Let's give it a sniffy sniff.
Now this is another thing
that's been interesting
about the wine world.
This comes across very perfume
oriented, very big flavor
call it like jam.
I don't know if you've,
you know, if you walked
into like an old family, like
your grandmother's kitchen
when she made hand made jam.
Now I had a Soviet grandmother, you know
that my grandma, Astra, passed
away a couple years ago.
My dad's mom, may she rest in peace.
But she was an OG.
Like she would be like, let's go outside
and pick raspberries,
get all cut up and crap
come back to the kitchen
and like make that jam.
And, and so I remember
very authentic, clean
like not go to whole foods
and buy the raspberries.
I mean go outside.
Or like when you're on the highway driving
there's some like wild raspberries
pull over and pick them. Ruth St. John,
we did that with it's called
svetaboy boy go Google that.
That's like that magic tea
that my great grandmother
and grandmother believed
in the most like literally,
"grandma I broke my arm,"
'drink some sveta boy,'
"grandma I think she has cancer,"
'drink some sveta boy'
Like it solved everything.
So I remember doing a lot
of picking in the 80's.
This smells like that to me,
a kitchen where homemade
jam is being made, however
to go to the extreme
in the other direction
it also smells like, do
you remember Now and Later,
the candy, there's a
candy name Now and Later.
And like, they were hard
and you would bite them.
But like, it smells like artificial candy.
So this is a really
interesting juxtaposition
on one side of the bouquet, I
smelled that authentic berry
but then I also get a lot of candy.
I would for a more contemporary candy.
It smells like a bag of Skittles.
So you can feel the fakeness of the candy.
Interesting, this is
where the wine world has
gone a little bit, a
little bit out of, you know
if you watch Wine Library
TV in that five-year
my pallet bounced around
a lot of these cult wines.
I love them.
I hated them.
It was like a love, hate kind of thing.
It's like, it's like dessert.
Like sometimes a great piece
of chocolate cake is just a good idea.
Sometimes after you eat it,
you want to punch yourself
in the face that's what's happened
with a lot of these California wines.
Don't lead the witness DRock,
Blackberry, black currant, dark
chocolate, high cocoa count.
This is like real chocolate flavors.
Like not like, yay, let's
eat a Kit-Kat no, let's go
into like a really healthy
store and buy a bar
for like $28 because
somebody climbed a mountain
and pick this and then
like brought it back
out a propeller plane in a jar.
And this is the cocoa
that makes this $28 wildly
overpriced hand curated chocolate
which is probably good for you.
And you should probably like it
but it is a bitter that
is mixed in with a lot
of strawberries and blueberries,
blackberries and cherries
black and red fruit in this wine.
However,
this is really disappointing to say.
It is now after tasting this wine
I'm going to give it one more second
but there's was gonna be a tough statement
in my opinion.
It is now of my opinion
that Joseph Phelps Insignia
and this, and I was a little bit worried.
I wanted to try this.
It's a really big time wine.
The ratings are through the
roof, 96, 97, everywhere.
I have had two or three
Insignias since I last left you
in the last decade where
it really struck me
like this wine should
really still be $39.99
not 200 bucks a bottle.
I'm in my zone right now.
That was like, I was out.
And like, you know, you
know, you know, you know
I'm in client life now with VaynerMedia.
So the clients I go with
Insignia I'm like, all right
let's order a bottle of Insignia.
So I was very like in business mode
not really analyzing and rating a wine
as like sit here and analyze
it and rate this wine.
And it's funny.
This is like riding a bike.
I'm really taken aback by this.
I believe that Insignia
has jumped the shark.
Like, I feel like I'm
in The Fonz right now wearing
a leather coat on a ramp.
And, but I also feel like I'm
your friend that tells you
that Santa Claus doesn't
exist in second grade.
This...
Is a wine that
I mean, this is crazy that
they want $200 for this.
When I think about the sheer
number of California Cabernets
and red blends and wines, even
from places like Argentina
Maremma Tuscany..
that are 20, 30, 40, $50 a bottle
I would argue that Insignia
has now found itself
in that classic place of colleges
that aren't one of the top 10
in the country where you're going to spend
a ton of money and the
diploma's not worth it as much
in the real world fashion
brands that costs $800
for a scarf because it's
got the right pattern on it.
And everyone thinks it's Gucci.
And I mean, slang term, Gucci,
not specifically calling out Gucci,
this is a wine that is now a status
in my opinion.
It's known by the big dogs.
And I think people are
paying at least a $100
if not $125, if not $150 too
much for this bottle of wine.
To me, this is far from the 96
and 97 and it's playing off its pedigree.
I think that the world
respects the past too much.
That doesn't mean disrespect.
It means it holds up yesterday.
Instead of looking at today,
it's like being emotional
about having stores in
the world of the internet.
It's like being emotional about Instagram.
When TikTok is emerging.
It is like not adjusting
to post COVID life
and flying to every meeting
in 2024 and not doing zooms.
I think Insignia is holding
onto a past of the late
90's and early 00's.
I think this is a 50 to
$70 wine at this point.
I think this is a 90 point
wine, not a 97 point wine.
And I think I might even be
caught being kind and 90 points.
This is a colossal failure
of a wine, in my opinion
if it's thinks that it's
worth 200 bucks these days.
And I'm curious for the
comments and I'll look
for the shares, but this is
what's wrong about consumer
products when you pay for
reputation versus what
they're putting out.
I think this is, I think
there's a lot of wines
of California at 40, 50 bucks
that are equal to this wine.
I really genuinely do.
Four really interesting wines:
Cali Blends, Barolo,
Pinot and Sauvignon Blanc.
Remember the themes of Wine Library TV.
Before I leave you try new
things, trust your own palette.
You may disagree with all
four of my reviews here
try new things, try new
things, try new things.
That is how you become
great at wine because you
get happiness through it.
I wish you all so much
health, so much health
during this holiday season.
And remember, I have
a question of the day.
And so here's my question.
Since I last saw you, what
has become your favorite wine?
Whether it's an exact
winery or a type of wine
please leave that in the
comments of social media.
Something that barely
existed when we started
Wine Library TV,
and remember you with a little bit of me
we're changing the wine
world, whether they like it or
not.
YouTube watcher what's up?
It's Gary V. First of
all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also want to ask you
please subscribe because my
commitment and exploration
of YouTube is about to
explode stories, polls
more content, more engagement,
more surprise and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.